je vous dire dans un instant ce que je
pense de chacun de vous
mais ce sera pendant la pub pour ne pas
choquer les téléspectateurs
les cherry dans un instant on aura notre
ami que j'aime beaucoup artus artus
chanson
[Applaudissements]
vient me voir moi est-ce que 6e
passionnel team bien entendu un ancien
des linkup
[Musique]
comme ça on va le faire on s'en
remettait le débit notation en école
[Musique]
ne me demandez pas d'où je viens les c4
et sur mon chemin mais qu'est ce que ça
peut changer
au fond
[Musique]
on se fait du mal qu en tout cas j'adore
cette agression de touche tous un par un
mais qu'est ce que ça peut changer
au fond
[Musique]
on va tous quelques pas sur le chemin de
hollande
les chats
et bah
achat
abondée toile
on se croit pourquoi changer les couples
noah
jo
monde et toi
[Applaudissements]
et pas le matin de toutes les histoires
donc on affirme ça fait plaisir on a
changé
ses méthodes et ses amis ta gueule
[Applaudissements]